today on our show I eat a spider
spider-man we are gonna shoot webs to
flip our own webs of joy or displeasure
mostly joy kind of entirely the movies
pretty amazing today I'm fat man I'm
Batman we blow spider-man homecoming
which is weird to say kids high school
flicks maybe we shouldn't say that we
give a hand job there's a spider-man
home you got a third base i'm spectrum
and home gets hard today i'm batman twit
Batman on Batman welcome to Batman on
spider-man I have a look at it right at
least for today I'm Kevin Smith I am
mark Bernard uh we live in Hollywood me
and Mark we do so naturally we have seen
spider-man I saw it like you know left
leg like ignore me
as did I will tell last night so just
like you guys we put down our
hard-earned schmekel Sue's borrow from
Rick amore and stepped up and and said
cake shoot me web web shoot made me full
of web you me empty all those cartridges
of web fluid into my face neck and chest
cocking ropes of pleasure ah and wasn't
anything so we didn't go together
where'd you go I went out by where I
live out in Winnetka California I did a
show and uh give out your address well I
didn't give it all out it's just some
Winnetka nobody can find it sounds like
the Indian burial site at home was just
like all I needed was the name you are
mine art when are gonna zoom enhance I
live in Hollywood
ah big tried finally we're in Hills
welcome tomorrow you're not helping but
I want to see it at Irvine I was in
Irvine doing a Jay and Silent Bob Dole's
show the Irvine improv plug for so
that's over and afterwards that said
Muse we're going into that edwards
multiplex for me to go see some
spider-man : home kitty put up a fight
early night dogs he loved that kid is
he's a great bit away from everybody's
like she's asleep let's go see Spidey
thank God he did go because he's the
kind of dude that's like I want to sit
there during the trailers he's wheeling
and dealing with the concession stand
like you know oh we're kind of close now
and he's like please just make me
pretzels for me and my friend you could
text me when they're done cuz I'm gonna
be watching the movie hook this [ __ ] up
in a span of four minutes and [ __ ] I was
like we're getting pretzel stick who the
[ __ ] barter for concessions has a whole
different business to the show business
we're in I did not realize I was on the
table he's smart enough to know the real
money is in the snack
so he got us some snacks hooked us up J
West a West brother rich and we went
theaters packed and some of the people
who had been in the Jay and Bob show we
told him were told to see the movie so
they were there as well and he had a
bunch of people there appreciated this
talk for a movie that let's be honest
we've seen a few times we've seen a
couple Spider Men in our lifetime five
prior to this we're old men so we've
seen all of the spider-man kids I
remember when a young Tobey Maguire
wasn't even that young he was like 45
played spider-man
I remember when an old Nicholas Hammond
oh my god that's where they write it
that's how far we go back man when the
little boy from Sound of Music we
spider-man the dude is like I'm still
alive why do I get left off the list it
always starts with [ __ ] Toby Toby
Toby what about Nick no dick like that's
why we don't put you on the list
drop the deck maybe we will he's like
I'll never drop that I drop a dick in
your face Haman stop play my hammond
organ that's a really good musical on
thank you thank you well anyway I can't
say you know what for the record
McCammon not that guy at all no lovely
person he's a pastor so go with God but
he was the original live-action
spider-man but there's always another
guy that gets left off because we didn't
know who was under the mask remember uh
The Electric Company oh yeah those hang
out with you inside a man where are you
what is it where are you coming from
spider-man
nobody knows who you are and then they
would have an adventure yeah like Morgan
Freeman we kind of slide in is easy
reader but like a Spider Man what's up
and he would go whoop and they would put
a thought balloon over his head with the
with the dots which was as a kid it
frustrated me because I was like that's
incorrect because he's communicating to
whoever's in the scene I thought bubbles
yeah thank you you know what I'm saying
where was Mark in my childhood come on
because I would turn to my parents and
say this and they would look at each
other sadly like he's doomed never gonna
have to listen why did he tear what
about something that doesn't matter
great the boy is useless is what my
father would and then me an entire state
over was like why that doesn't make any
sense what we had
Aquaman type communication as we have
before the International Aquaman strike
so you can talk to fish mark barnard in
here Fish Face gigs don't eat me look
you'll never understand it but it's
better than some in any event closer but
further away there was a [ __ ] Spider
Man and they never revealed them and he
never spoke they never spoke it was very
I was so stylized so awesome but he
taught a lot of us to read and stuff
yeah so thanks mighty yeah so anyway
they've been many live-action Spidey's
or you know not many a small well yeah
tell many if you include all the [ __ ]
theme parks and the dudes down on Sunset
and they really hollow the whole like
overseas contingent of like Japanese
spider-man and Korean spider-man and
Middle Eastern spider-man many people
have pulled on the colors as they say
red blue and black
yeah red black and blue red black and
blue sound sexy dead nipple many people
pulled on the the masks created by the
great Steve Ditko and and of course the
amazing Stanley I'm going to I'm going
to here's my hot take do it they're
coming for me you can hear a panel I
think this kid Tom Holland my favorite
spider-man and Eddie any iteration
including the confident cartoons Wow
yes I think this boy's got it this is my
idea of spider-man what spider-man
homecoming had going for it that no
other comic book movie seems to have
going for it that I can recollect even
kick-ass when he was set in high school
was the simple joy of a spider-man story
where you know look there are many
different types of spider-man tales
they've told over the years except
Adrian Toomes backing up trying to get
some [ __ ] derelict equipment that came
from we've got a gory [ __ ] yeah for each
it to a [ __ ] I love that this is the
this is the one that I can so get behind
because I'm like this feels like
spider-man
there was a joy to this movie yeah I
mean that's what I always responded to
even you know say what you will about
Tobey Maguire those first couple of
movies for the first time that I can
remember can
one must be the absolute joy of having
superpowers of lighting with a cool yeah
when it's like [ __ ] I can do this this
is awesome except if only you had an
actor who could express that type of
exuberant joy because if I remember that
scene correctly it was woo hoo which is
like it at the 12 on the toby scale Toby
felt that was too big I can't go hotter
than this
Josh's I don't McGuire's a [ __ ] you guys
oh ma Seabiscuit I were - wham - he biz
kid well I wasn't but I did ride
Seabiscuit right to the top of the box
of [ __ ] you two pricks - dominated his
web-shooters on us [ __ ] em all this Tom
Holland kid has the name tom hollie
fantastic loved him in Civil War you got
to love your spider-man you gotta love
your Peter Parker this is what I'll say
about those previous iterations
everyone's always like Sam Raimi's
amazing which is therapy you can take
Mesa sorry Sam Raimi's are amazing
yes , his spider-man movies not to be
confused as amazing spider-man 2 marc
webb yes no it's not confuse anything
with us
spider-man 2 with Doc Ock wonderful
superhero movie yes one of my favorites
this for my money and it's not a you
know like [ __ ] I'm not lowering one to
raise another but this is what I wanted
out of a spider-man movie particularly I
wanna min high school
I want them getting used to the powers
and abilities I want to see him fight in
one of his classic villains but I do not
want to see him [ __ ] take on the
Green Goblin one more no we'll give it
that moratorium on all Green Goblin
nonsense they showed us the [ __ ]
vulture they showed us one of the best
scenes you'll see in a movie this year
when Peter goes to pick up his [ __ ]
homecoming date just backs and that you
don't have to spoil ups that's it that's
the scene yeah we'll foil it later
because we'll get to the spoiler part of
the review total we are talk about it
but even still it's one of the most
riveting pieces of cinema you'll see
yeah all [ __ ] year and it's three
people in a car yeah and it don't
involve [ __ ] silly ass cast
it's crazy and don't get me wrong I like
those silly ass costumes their rendition
of the vulture as you know we've seen it
now for months in the trailers but
perfectly terrifying perfectly plausible
yes a perfectly cast and took the words
right out of my mouth
absolutely perfectly cast spider-man in
the first spider-man movie and I thought
Tobey Maguire was a really good Peter
Parker and I thought that rendition of
spider-man was okay thinking with penis
didn't match the performance Toby's not
a quickie guy not at all
so beauty pariour he felt for him but
him as spider-man it's like wow my
spider-man's blade not white funny or
zania but just like lighter you later in
the next set Andrew Garfield Andrew
Garfield I thought his spider-man was
pitch perfect his Peter Parker was just
far too sexy so far a few sexy hair is
too good oh my god like there was
nothing about him he was too cool he was
Flash Thompson really yeah so but but
you know not because any fault of his
own that kids just Keeley's what is it a
little asses on an almost 30 year old
man as well X because boy he wants to
play that role remember he showed me on
the con and he took the mask off good
man he kind of got tough to the wayside
but he did it he's like a good
spider-man in a not great spider-man
movie agreed and unfortunately he's been
saddled with till like the George
Lazenby of the sequence and that's the
kids are bosses who's Elisaveta if
you're coming to LA and George Lazenby
how dare you is that a weapon George
maybe a shot of all qpp so this one yeah
the Colin kid kids my little Dutch boy
amazing excellent Peter Parker
excellent spider like always bashful the
way he wants spider-man to be bashful
like he's not an ugly man at all he's
definitely handsome because he's a movie
star in a Hollywood major motion picture
but he's not so handsome that it
distracts you from the awkwardness from
the the social misfit nature of him from
the kid who cannot work up the Moxie to
talk to the girl that you know he likes
that he knows he likes it who even knows
who likes him but can't get there until
the movie acts
get him there right like so much of this
really like we talked about it's a teen
movie in addition to being a spider-man
movie and so it's hitting all of those
beats of the learning to discover who
you are and who you're meant to be
learning how to fit in or not fit in
with whatever clique you feel like you
want to fit in how how to find for
yourself and define for yourself with
successes and this is what this movies
about in addition to in being spider-man
sorry I thought it was about to be a dog
fight who
we're just if you had to like work
what's your mini review somebody's like
hey what's the big spider-man
I will say that that it is my favorite
spider-man movie yes and not quite by
far but absolutely yes I do that there
is still no scene in this movie that
does for me what the elevated subway
train did in the second experiment
wonderful sequence in that I get amazing
sequence and in that sequence of
capsulated everything that you want from
spider-man I mean that sequence met very
nearly perfect cinematic sequence were
it not for the fact that when they take
his mask off the actors you know have
the audacity to deliver the written line
let's say he's just a kid even though
Tobey Maguire is clearly 72 years old
regular magic are gonna get afraid a
little bit if you on mass Tom Horne
somebody's like he's just a kid you
build his Jacek okay look at that guy
you know I mean I think that that even
seen this movie underscored for me that
spider-man is a hero defined by will you
know the end and you'll notice in each
spider-man movie the cast of what makes
spider-man spider-man is one of one guy
trying to hold something back that's
bigger than he is and putting himself on
the line for that thing it's Tobey
Maguire trying to hold a subway train
off from an elevated platform it's Tom
Holland trying to keep the stand on a
ferry from splitting in half it's even
Andrew Garfield at some point having to
swing to link them and having to do some
other holy thing and they just let him
into usually a messianic pose too it's
you absolutely great pose but
Oh drop of Scott stop neither stop it
Stephanie rapid estaphan oh you [ __ ]
gay joke but this movie has two of them
it's got the Staten Island Ferry
sequence in the very end he's buried
under an avalanche of whatever permits
it does I'm taking the hippos and list
the building its reservoirs of will it's
about discovering how much of you is
left inside you know what I had when I
was watching that sequence when he was
buried under the rubble and like haha I
was like oh [ __ ] I mean I think it'd
happen here you could totally get away
with fearful symmetry that Craven sort
of last hunt well the greatest
spider-man stories ever [ __ ] told
cravings last time where he gets hunted
down by like a goofy ass [ __ ] villain
and his Kraven the hunter it was like I
will [ __ ] the spider-man and you know
has done it in comics and count and
cartoons for years and in this wonderful
[ __ ] story he takes out spider-man
he's in the black costume like the neck
dark place ticket was awesome yeah I
think I think it is if I remember
correctly yeah cuz I see the image
coming out of the graves in the black
colors I don't think it's red we may be
getting a bunch of talk backs right now
he creates the red costume
yeah those and if it's true I'll take it
then I am the fat ass any event Craven
takes him out with a neck dart tranq
take and buries him alive in a [ __ ]
coffin here lies Peter Parker [ __ ]
Crimson storyline and then he goes puts
on the costume and he goes out to be
spider-man
yeah and kill people a spider-man and
[ __ ] like that and then Peter Parker has
to dig himself out of the [ __ ] grave
it's amazed I mean years before we saw
the bride Beatrice dig yourself out of
the gril vol.2
spider-man there he was in the comics
[ __ ] digging himself out of the
goddamn grave and that that image
reminded me of that one my feeling on
books of all time I don't think they
were intentionally trying to evoke it
but right then and there yet this feels
more like a comic book that I've read
than any of the previous spider-man
adventures and I'll even include the
amazing spider-man not the amazing
Sonoran [ __ ] Raimi's spider-man 2 yeah I
mean I love it I think is well at old
story and Raimi's fantastic filmmaker
but this homecoming felt like reading a
spider-man comic yeah reminded me of my
childhood because he's never he's never
winning in this movie until the very end
even when he wins he loses even when he
succeeds it's a failure on the ground of
the Marvel Universe absolutely you know
and to watch this guy strive like I said
it's about will it's about you know like
like Stallone uses a Iraqi it's about
how hard you can get hit and keep moving
forward
it's always forward it's just trying to
get it it's like he's a he's a striving
hero in a way that like Iron Man is not
in a way that Thor is not in a way that
Captain America is not in his full
Captain America form like he struggles
against like crisis and conscience and
whatever but it's never will Captain
America do it can Captain America do it
no we totally get that he can can he's
[ __ ] Captain America but here's a guy
who's trying to be a hero and trying so
hard to be a hero and the watching that
pain and that anguish of him getting so
close all the time and not realizing
he's succeeding through the effort is
what makes it both an awesome like high
school comedy that's funny and
everything but it's a tragic story put
that on a poster lovely ah [ __ ] well
cover the whole [ __ ] thing it the
fact that it was high school and we
lived in high school wasn't like we're
in high school for a little period and
then like high school we stayed in high
school lived in high school and it felt
more like the high school experience not
necessarily mine but then I'd seen
portrayed in other versions of the movie
again maybe because the kids looked like
[ __ ] kid yeah that helps something to
be said for that you know I like some of
their recasting of characters like flash
smart idea is not bullying he's not a
bully because Raqqa again is bully he's
a bully but it's not a jock bully but
it's not a physical bully because it's
like of course he couldn't be in a Peter
Parker we know that like he's already
[ __ ] spider-man that's not a threat
and also it's like that's you know the
joys of the jock bully I'm not going to
say it's over but it's not being [ __ ]
shitty to other people
two main of athletes anymore you know in
the world of the internet [ __ ] people
pray people that normally would be
preyed upon prey upon [ __ ] others so
I liked it I liked the kind of flip of
that he's a bully of pretty wasn't a bit
exactly risk it bully yeah which I guess
at the end of the day like you know
that's like Reggie right again Archie
world yeah got money there's always that
thing of the here's a person who has
more than everybody Lords it over
everyone you know and that that's a good
way to put a spin on flash saying it's
been we called it we did maybe change
boilers sigh yeah from here on out maybe
yeah good this will be the spoiler
section of the review don't watch this
part until you've seen the spider-man
Home Coming yeah the as as we say when
we want a teaser Tom looks years ago it
feels like years ago does it might be
wouldn't be awesome if this trailer is
positing that like hey this pretty girl
is actually Mary Jane but what if it's
them daya who we don't even get a name
what if she's Mary Jane sort of she's MJ
yeah as revealed by the end of the movie
she's Michele but her friends call her
MJ and she didn't have any friends
before now but she's a nerd she's on the
sort of intellectual decathlete keen on
who she is the [ __ ] than Dez okay him
god damn she was great she I'm you I
talk about doing a lot with a little
yeah cuz it's like a sue song to song to
song to song sue song yeah but every
time she's on screen like you're like
shut up shut up and then you lean in
yeah like disaffected teens she does
really well sanely well you know just
the character itself II like I like that
character anyway like Ned but like Ned
is given they might as well call this
movie
Ned homecoming is [ __ ] all about Ned
man and you know I wonder if I Sir Tom
Holland was just like oh my god I'm
happy to be spider-man at all but hum
likes but if I'm Tom I'll and I'm like
hey again with the Ned scene yet let's
just throttle back like 40 percent on
the Midna sauce where we can we 30% more
Tony Stark I think we all great
that wasn't it but they went for a lot
more net a lot more natty thank God the
kid who plays meds up to the task
oh yeah he's so much fun nice to see a
[ __ ] heavy kid a real looking kid in
my estimation one of my people in a
[ __ ] motion picture and a superhero
day - and it would be so easy to dislike
Ned because Ned in this movie is the guy
who's unable to keep Peter secret like
that is the why he won't be identified
as well oh because he's so gregarious
like wonderful in that process like if
you knew [ __ ] your friend with
spider-man you may not tell the press
but you know you know yeah your wife is
your [ __ ] girlfriend your boyfriend's
[ __ ] you know people who playing
hockey with like eventually you would
feel like like he's gonna get you I know
who that is
he's gonna get you in trouble but you
don't hate him for getting you in
trouble right well I came sec oh no
Peter no spider-man it's like well that
right there and right out of a script
written by [ __ ] screenwriters 101 he
get into a rogue moment the third act he
absolutely I would it's there's a bit of
and this is not a criticism this is an
observation exiled beard
let me prep for CeBIT preface everything
I'm going to say with I can't do this
[ __ ] I never could make a movie as
wonderful as what I saw last night
spider-man Alan [ __ ] that being said
a lot of preamble and I forgot where I
was headed toward let's rewrite of 101
ah yes to give a moment of use beyond
I'm your buddy right to the character
you know arc they call it sometimes
spoiler spoiler spoilers for Ned to be
able to use the vision web shooter at
the proper moment is both you know
[ __ ] hey man that came out of the
PlayBook of 96 movies that made a
hundred million dollars or more and and
and kind of paint-by-number like that's
it's nobody's [ __ ] breaking tradition
doing that that being said this movie is
so well crafted so [ __ ] charming it
is such a charm Factory and you're
having such a good time that even when
that happens and moment and that's not
big complaint but even when there are
moments that exist in the world of like
it's a movie there better be this this
and this or else people are going to be
the satisfied you never feel like [ __ ]
they derailed like he's got to fight the
vulture in the third
going to happen probably also going to
have to fight the shocker
to get to the vulture going to happen
and the problem too is like they give
you such an amazing scene maybe half an
hour 20 minutes before that not even 10
15 minutes before that between you know
that's really the the best spider-man
verse the vulture scene in the movie and
it's not physical at all and you're not
moving a camera there's no special
effects it comes down to great writing
great staging and great surprise
something they've kept under wraps kept
webbed up and and and you going in I
don't think anybody realizes it's about
to happen is great I'm not even calling
them night twist this is great it's
almost a great I give it time see how it
ages but you could put it up there with
my guy and your father
to some degree since they haven't earned
like that amount of Star Wars prior to
this today about five others funny
memories but isn't it Saturn is it big
it's a great twist it's a big twist and
it is also a screenwriting 101 twist of
like and again spoilers Peter Parker has
been angling towards his woman named Liz
woman girl named Liz in high school
super big crush whatever find Alan who a
lot of us who grew up with spider-man
you know they were like oh and this girl
will be playing lizallen yeah like oh
there's alan right oh [ __ ] knows
she's Ned Ned leads and live Alan or
Peter Parker's friends in high school
yeah so like he finally did works up the
machi basket at homecoming dance she
says yes he goes to her house to pick
her up she is a young woman of color he
shows up at her house who answered the
door but the vulture because the vulture
is her dad because of course it's her
dad great seeing it's written like that
that's a great moment door opens I was
in a packed theater hmm did your theater
reacts and on every little [ __ ] a
literal vocal utterance from nearly
everybody in the theater
somebody had spoiled it for me it has
its time but I didn't care I wasn't mad
because when they told me I was like oh
my god that's [ __ ] bro
so almond surrounded by 300 people who
won oh and kept chattering for the next
minute about to [ __ ] cool on Infinite
that and then when they introduced like
his wife her mom comes out man you know
people look oh it's it's like you know
we talked about it just before we rolled
it's it's diversity as sub versity like
I'll put that on a [ __ ] t-shirt that
put that on the poster that one's even
shorter to say I mean it you don't think
it possible because your brain doesn't
go there your brain won't connect those
dots
except of course it's possible I got why
couldn't a white dude be married to a
black lady didn't have a black kid or
mixed-race kid who then goes to high
school and also it's a movie so you
better be sure that everyone's related
in one way or another they get it later
well all roads lead to Peter Parker
absolutely and so then you get this
amazing scene when the audience is
surprised your character surprised you
then put all three of them in a car the
girl Peter likes Peter and then the
vulture are driving to the high school
and the vulture doesn't know the Peter
spider-man Peter knows the vultures the
vultures yeah because he doesn't really
have a mask he's got a little vision
ocular things what everybody knows who
even for the first like for the first
twenty percent of that sequence because
it starts in the house moves in the car
and it's fantastic sequence worth the
price of admission for a loan and all
the movie is [ __ ] a fun ride man it's
like going to a theme park and riding a
great rollercoaster and [ __ ] like that
but this is exquisite this is like they
stopped don't even stop the roller
coaster in the middle of the roller
coaster somebody gives you the most
[ __ ] exquisite oral pleasure you've
ever had man or woman don't matter it's
like oh I didn't know this was going to
happen to already good enough nagamma
gate all the sudden like for the first
15 20 percent of scene Peter knows and
tooms doesn't right then Liz starts like
faintly I give my beaters friends with
spider-man and Peter was like he was
also with me in Washington DC's like
Peter will you were you upset to be in
that elevator I actually did make it in
the elevator but good things but and
you'll see are piecing it together in
the process of this car ride you see him
put together that Peter Parker is
spider-man we're on we're we're with
Peter Parker at the beginning of the
scene because we're like we did we were
shocked as [ __ ] that this is happening
but tombs doesn't start putting it
together
until a good percentage into the
sequence and it's fun watching that
and then you know watching the tenor of
that scene change and watch and looking
for you know and and for Liz you know
it's he's like I want to talk to you I
wanna have dad conversation with your
friend and the whole audience is like oh
it's a wonderful piece of storytelling
they're like oh yeah they're gonna have
a dad conversation alright just as that
I beat the [ __ ] Bulger that man like
everybody in that car has a different
movie they're playing in and watching
that movie collide in the car is kind of
amazing to see and right before the
titular homecoming in question although
we know it refers to a bunch of things
but you know there's a homecoming dance
in the third act of this thing and they
you know it's a it's a tease you get its
its Peter Parker's true story because
all the fun is happening and he gets to
run through it and disappoint somebody
in an effort to go save the day
yeah and the day saving is not about
like there's a ring of garbage in the
sky we're all [ __ ] doomed it's very
localized it's what I loved about the
movie and like you know they play with
it it's in the trailer and stuff he's
like why can't you just be a friendly
neighborhood spider-man and stuff like
that I mean they even include like the
written note at the end
yeah and [ __ ] like that's wonderful but
it's very it's not it's not fly remember
like the Sam Raimi movies where you know
Green Goblin also gets hit by a rock and
like you must was spider-man your much
little a New York and yelling and I can
say this right after September 11th and
we're all very like to flag and it's
Lincoln thing and stuff but it didn't
feel authentic this felt very authentic
and felt very much like this is the hero
Queens it's not even like all of Queens
oh the Queens he can get to on mass
transit or say wing two of these luck
they do a great bit with him in the
suburbs yeah I'm not being able to swing
in running across a goat I got so tricky
blasters whose web into the air but
there's nobody grab Ozzie how did you
feel about the the sort of Iron Man
ization of the Spidey suit I'm okay with
that but I unless I missed it a lot of
[ __ ] I was sold in the trailer wasn't
there
I never once heard the suit say like you
have 149 web shooting options listener
is it yeah when he's trying to sneak up
on the Shocker as they're waiting for
those vans to drop and he's like I got I
got
Kizer webs is the kids there are 243
different options for I saw in the end
credits so that was Jennifer come on now
that was kind of sweet which is adorable
because she's married to Paul Bettany oh
I feel uttering in the Marvel Universe
by web she was once the bride of David
Banner she was she was a Betty banner at
one point where Paul Bettany was a voice
of Iron Man suit and now Jennifer
Connelly's avoids the Spider Man suit
that's [ __ ] you isn't that adorable
oh my god are they marketing that is
anyone think about that I don't that's
like one of those Kennedy and Lincoln
jobs on President's Day why wow that's
really sweet
and I like that I'm okay with the Iron
Man ization of the said of the suit
it gave us somewhere to go I look I'll
be honest with you I wasn't going to
want to watch that homemade soup though
[ __ ] movie hoodie suit at a certain
point like come on but uh so I like and
I like you know he's part of the Marvel
Universe and Iron Man is the Batman
slash you know [ __ ] tech genius of
that universe why not you know given me
we've already seen the upgrade in Civil
War mm-hmm so you know is the only new
information was oh it's got an onboard
right which I think it allowed him to
like here think about it your comic book
reader for years whenever spider-man's
by himself he has these soliloquies or
internal monologues and stuff like that
you can't really do that in a movie it
looks goofy you can have him you know
expositing information by way of talking
to his suit and then also you get the
comedic beats of the soupy and like talk
to her Peter
she's pretty yeah because it really
[ __ ] got why are people against that
no I mean you know why are people
hugging now I guess it you know it's
just the the the finding ways for Peter
to still be Peter for spider-man to be
the spider-man we want them to be and
how much they shrink their haunt their
own hallway by adding you know hey tech
to the zoo
it does kind of take away from the
scientific brilliance of Peter programs
except that you still get some of that
like you get the big waste trapped in
damage control which again I love the
fact that damage control is in this
movie and I loved seeing Dwayne McDuffie
name in that final scroll at the end a
Swede I god that's good
I bought do damage control off the rack
first four issues when I was good yeah
that's good [ __ ] but when he's trapped
in that giant [ __ ] bunker and he's
got a I got assigned to my way out of
this like this is 243rd combination of
things to get us out of this giant all
right awesome Spidey that's cool we saw
I'm developing a web fluid mm-hmm what
you guys another thing this is a movie
that posits that
it's not organic web shooters right
right then and there it's all tech it's
and even if Tony builds a better version
of the suit Peter developed the
technology right so I'm okay with that
that didn't I didn't bump into that at
all everyone presented with the 247
options just just give me webs I don't I
don't want great surprise ricochet waves
I just [ __ ] one way I like the idea
of like look at all the tricks and he
gets comfortable I mean that felt like a
trope like this suits tricked out and
then we're digging a suit away a little
prick and then he's got to do it without
it and this is the wonderful shot of him
looking in the reflection of the half my
time at mask after Peter Parker
beautiful yes visual storytelling it's
tough before he has to you know Peter
Parker up and become the spine being one
of my favorite little tiny beads was
Donald Glover he's gone I got a nephew
who lives in this yes you know that is
Miles Morales that's the first reference
and here's what I win deed last night I
was going home I got no inside
information information okay if your
[ __ ] was quite a man y'all [ __ ] where
your [ __ ] guy I got no inside info
here's just something I was reading
about on the ride home
we know we're heading into Avengers
infinity board yes imagine it but not
again is ain't predicated on nothing but
imagine if in the end of it you know
because all those contracts are getting
big for the stars of the Marvel Universe
and they've been saying after the
Avengers of infinity war word in a
completely different phase of the Marvel
Universe and things will [ __ ] change
indefinitely or permanently
so what they're communicating as far as
I understand is like you know get ready
as they go battled battle phantos get
ready to [ __ ] lose some big guns yeah
so imagine this some world where you've
got Tony Stark gets killed in infinity
war who could take over the suit the kid
he's been mentoring Peter Parker who's
already got a suit the talks to him and
[ __ ] then who takes over the spider-man
suit prowlers kid and they called him
the Prowler okay they were looking up
his records in Raleigh his nephew then
suddenly you can see it working I don't
know that's the way my specialist
armchair writing a little better version
I'm sure but I mean once once you
establish that Miles Morales exists in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe means he's
going to get a suit one it means that at
some point and you know what we saw the
[ __ ] suit at the end of this movie
when he does that's it that's what it
was yeah that will be Miles Morales a
suit when he shows up and it kind of
looked like my offense and you know what
you didn't want Peter in that tune
you're like Peter that's not your suit I
know it's great walk away man but it's
just like it's not for me and then I
thought alright maybe they'll give it to
him in space by Pacific when they goes
inviting the infinity work still need
cosmic armor stuff yeah remember that
Spidey goes Cosme remember this armored
Spidey at one point like they give them
that armor in space and [ __ ] so I love
that too we know next time we see
spider-man it's going to be up in space
fightin with [ __ ] the Avengers
against Thanos and shoes it's nice to
see this very localized insanely
localized high school and then the
surrounding area of Queens maybe a trip
to Maryland Washington DC yeah school
trip which makes sense nice to see him
working on the small level because most
of those Marvel movies are on the
grandiose yeah like not every movie
needs a bit about saving the world they
need to be about saving your world yeah
and that's what makes it work it's a
charm factor this whole [ __ ] movie I
I don't need to compare and contrast
where it is
with other spider-man movies but it is
my favorite because I need to do it but
I don't need to but I think it owns this
it is hands-down the spider-man movie I
will watch more than once I think I've
seen every one of the
spider-man movies once never necessarily
felt the need to go back for themself
knock they were bad just like then I get
it that's a spider-man this felt like my
spider-man's behind me the spider-man
comics are first made when I was kid I
was there for the whole [ __ ] ride I
thought was ingenious - I saw some
article online where somebody was like
this is the rebirth of comic book movies
because this is the first time that
somebody took a different genre and
married it to come out of a comic book
male is a high school movie and
superhero movie I you know the guy I did
that yeah [ __ ] an alternator have you
seen all of the Marvel movies where one
of them is about magic one of them is
space one of them is a heist one of them
two conspiracies look at Logan
well it was not a traditional comic
movie I can register married to a
[ __ ] Western or film noir at the same
time so yeah I think it's great that you
know somebody got around and gone oh you
know who used to like the comic books
kids let's make a movie for the kid
thinking about us first of all what's
going to keep these two quiet for people
of their age you know they're like let's
make something for kids this movie's
gonna make gazillion bucks it's no
heartache but it has everything to do
the fact that like kids are gonna come
out and say it and kids will go see it
more than once thank bang I will see it
twice because I was always going to see
it twice yep but if you get a [ __ ]
sixteen-year-old kid to go to movies
three times over the course of summer
could is too [ __ ] hot out I want to
go inside and see something that's how
you make that Titanic that's how you
make that sweet [ __ ] Titanic that's
how they made the Titanic money wasn't
just like
fourteen-year-old girls you're like I
saw it once they saw it ten times and it
wasn't it like oh I love the boat going
down it was I love these two people
they're adorable and in this movie yes
like I want to see them fall in love and
in spider-man you just want to watch
Peter and Ned fall in love all over
again and Peter and and his crush Tony
Stark hats off to Robert Downey jr. as
usual I will watch Robert Downey Robert
Downey jr. could read my death warrant
to me and I'd be like all right did you
make that up on the spot
really as usual like how do I do that
with Evelyn commits most of those crimes
but boy he sold it my god you're so good
I'll watch him do anything I think he's
welcome addition to this movie I hope
he's always Peters mentor I'm glad that
he didn't overshadow the movie but I was
afraid by the trailers that it was a lot
of [ __ ] Iron Man and that's Shakopee
show the end of the trailer the two of
them
never in the movie like that was clearly
a we got to get people on board so look
they're flying together its first super
team up it's true and thought about yeah
I didn't do that interesting but he's
only in like three real scenes in this
movie and they're all good scene yes but
he's not in any way like Iron Man Plus
Spidey fight crime he's used absolutely
well Favreau gets come back and Babs
gets him loved happens like thank God I
cast myself as happy always yeah he gets
to come again it keeps on paying off my
house nice to see continuity there
there's a spoiler spoiler spoilers
gwyneth shows back out there so Potts
gets a little low it feels like an
ad-hoc sequel to Iron Man 3 as well a
little bit in many ways it's comeback
tour if you will and with winneth
there's always a backdoor GUP could a
JTAG up your I think that's how it works
in any event nice to see her on board
nice to see scorpion yeah he asked
credits I mean in school age I think it
was the scorpion he had one on his neck
did he know I wasn't sure if that was a
scorpion what should somebody do [ __ ] I
still jizz was oh my god but honestly I
had to explain it to Jason Mewes and I'm
like that didn't tip you off he goes I
saw our scorpion so that was kind of
nice mmm
would have been nice reviews in costume
or whatever we'll get there I met there
with everybody
there's he the prehensile tail like
crazy that was Chris uh Captain America
Evans yeah Chris Evans like proving once
again that he's adorably hysterical and
charming well does a series of pop up in
emotional high school videos the
funniest one was animal Brent's going I
think he's a war criminal now but
whatever thank you stay on the wrong
side of Evo because your gym teacher
those kind of Americans are you ought to
do push-ups and he's a war criminal now
but whatever get after it and it was
boggling I was like I wonder if he wrote
that joke
that's a serial but it fits in the
Marvel it's cool dude but I said and
again Tom Holland mazing but the
guy who deserves the you know given up
[ __ ] award
give him the wreath of the plaudits give
him the [ __ ] he's the MVP is when
Batman and Birdman came to be an actual
ruling Michael Keaton ain't cashing a
check in the hand for the first time
somebody constructed a Marvel villain
where you're like like this doing I get
it everything makes sense and you
remember everything about him and not
like what's his name what do you want
why he got that big hammer
like I love Gardens the galaxy but I can
try was like well Ronan the accuser it
wasn't was this before you who's he
accusing yeah why is it says it seems
less accusing more kilee Oppenheimer
Adrian Toomes a vulture they start the
movie yeah with his backstory so you
have no problem understanding like what
his motivations are and and they're
super simple and oddly altruistic yeah
like I'm looking out for my family yes
my family the guys I work with my family
at homes again for this ridiculous house
in the suburbs and this Jaguar that I
Drive all I want to do is protect my
people
and by doing in service of that I will
rob and I will steal and I will sell
weapons on the street and I will do any
number of bad things but I'm doing it
makes a lot - he takes a lot because
they play it like he might not have
known it and they take the life of a guy
who it's like well family piece of [ __ ]
should have died anyway but but I
thought that was an interesting choice
and I was like I wonder if that was him
gone I don't catch often this I don't
want to see him like murderers blood
lockers where do I go after that but you
know he does take a dude out and he's
like I thought that was the any gravity
gun in here so you get your cake and eat
it too and stuff then it also adds one
more feather to the whole new building
thank you nice but again I hats off to
the [ __ ] outfit too but but it's not
the outfit that makes the performance
and it's not like when you know uh
homeboy was Green Goblin the folk Oh
amazing actor and put a [ __ ] mask on
his face you couldn't like see or hear
any of the glorious performance
most of the vultures best stuff is out
of yeah the masks and all he does is he
wears a flake soup that's all he's got a
slight helmet on and he's got a bomber
Jackie expertly designed and that's it
and he looks like the vulture and you
buy every minute of it
his strongest work is out of the suit
yeah and and when I say like that does
not put down the other work all the
other work is the vulture is great and
stuff and all the other scenes are
really great but that [ __ ] sequence
of like are you who I think you are
discovering like is is fantastic it'll
be one of your favorite sequences in a
comic book movie of all time and that's
saying something because generally we
like the things that are big and
bombastic when UBS people was one of
your favorite Marvel sequence all time
to Oda airport scene Zuma Ward stuff
like that this is going to make that top
five
without yeah without effect like
literally doing something you could have
done with your friends if you had access
to like three very talented actors and a
great screen and again I mean Marvel is
also really good at that they will give
you the giant candy but they will also
punch you in the [ __ ] gut in the same
way in Civil War by the end of that
movie the best thing in that movie is
when Tony Stark realizes that Winter
Soldier killed his mom yeah oh god
you're right you know and that's the bit
where it's oh my god and you just watch
the dawning realization that caps best
friend killed his other best friend's
mom and that there was no actually
getting between and then gonna be no
peace between them we're gonna punch
each other til somebody stays down and
like that moment it's like but he killed
my mom it's there Klingon bastard killed
my son moment yeah where it's I'm
abandoning all reason because this is
just all emotion and just it's time to
punch things um he is he thankfully
spoilers I mean you a spoiled but
thankfully then [ __ ] kill him
starting to learn in these pictures put
them you know what a good word why do we
keep killing off all our here are bad
guys we can bring him back
especially in spider-man universe
getting he can beat six of them then
they could team up and we'd all be happy
because it'd be the Sinister's day and
they give they give a really nice reason
at the end of it why he doesn't reveal
who eat that he knows who Peter Parker
is because Peter Parker saved his life
and saved his kid's life and Peter
Parker's done more for this family
ultimately than he did but and so he
feels some debt sick now I I knew Peter
Parker was out to kill them already
at least for now yeah finally sorry well
maybe he's you know maybe he's like
build my own plan hmm
but maybe or maybe he's the guy that you
know [ __ ] recruits the sinister six
yeah
look I'm going to write they're doing a
good job without me they don't need our
help [ __ ] what a good time this isn't
the movies this movie just like
guardians of the galaxy is one of those
clerks really like take it take my money
I'll see this again I'll see it again in
the theater yes no for sure I enjoy the
[ __ ] out of this man hats off to it was
in John Watts
yes this kid he's got the world by the
balls
such talent on his kids on [ __ ] fair
it's good movie I saw some people came
down I'm like why all the [ __ ] action
sequences aren't staged very loose are
you [ __ ] high I couldn't do that I
could guarantee what anybody wrote that
his [ __ ] action sequences weren't
staged as well as could be couldn't do
it either like I looked at what he did I
was like that's impressive is all great
never once was like oh I feel they
skimped out if only a better director no
way and I think that movie has a voice
to it and you know there's often a
complaint from people going like well
Marvel stifles the individual voice and
there's just a Marvel boys and stuff but
that's if that's a flavor I saw cop car
that's a flavor to his work that he got
to carry over he's playing within the
lines yes but doing his thing and
bringing something to it a little bit
signature to it I love in this movie for
the history of these books as well and
you get shocker and you get the tinkerer
mm-hmm and you get what we said vulture
yeah and you get all of this and then
little nod to Miles Morales and you get
a little little touch of the future as
well you get a little Betty Brent
because here the end there no she's a
they have the very talented of the movie
where the two highschool journalists are
on camera yeah and the girl is Betty
brontosaurus
oh really yeah and spider-man once again
save blah blah blah
I've been Betty Brant for high school
weekly that's [ __ ] cool man I didn't
notice it at school the dude next to her
I saw him and Briggs b-bear he's got a
much bigger role on that talking that
movie's amazing okay spider-man
homecoming
it is a would you say based on the
trailers mm-hmm
as good as you thought it would be
better than you thought it'd be not as
good as you thought better than I
thought it would be really yeah I
thought it was exactly as good as I
thought would be based on the trailer so
I thought they did a great sell of that
and I'll be honest with you I've seen
I've devoured every [ __ ]
online so I've seen a lot of this movie
quickly I went in I was like I saw so
solvus the only thing they didn't show
anything up other than gonna kill you
newell family is that whole car sequence
I mean there's the the depth in the
center of this movie is what thing you
couldn't convey in the trailers and
that's what surprised me the most out of
it so like I went in expecting a good
time I did not expect it to land as hard
as it did towards the back half so good
so damn good that's off indeed I can't
swallow any more web fluid I think I've
polished the knob enough some people
like you're in [ __ ] get paid by these
people no honestly I blood wait it's
great hey man when somebody does
something that you [ __ ] like you know
I know it's the training of the Internet
to grouse about everything but how about
flipping the microscope when somebody
did something you like suck the [ __ ]
dick or lick the [ __ ] of it so you get
more of that otherwise you get some of
the old [ __ ] you don't want that name no
we got to go forward now now going
backwards man no more spider-man old man
spider-man boy nice velvet brought you
by will of associated rush you by name
block spider-man Home Coming man yeah
Swift with three fingers up Wow gonna go
forth whips up that's not bad but three
fingers means you are flipping and if
you are flipping that is code for you
can't do that anymore because gene
Simmons is trademarking this part of
this one he's doing he's doing that all
of them vitamin hat first
yeah won't even dr. Shuren chatter
before everybody had dr. chainsaw just
before spider-man well you did a [ __ ]
like oh come on man in a minimum and in
there so sorry Jade but we're tripping
yeah what's whipping we're flipping they
all were quick um go out and flip
yourself into a movie theater and check
out spider-man homecoming do it rockets
good doing first Batman on spider-man
mmm I've been Kevin Smith I've been
working hard come back next time we'll
talk about some more [ __ ] saying that
time same fat channels podcast calm or
youtube.com slash Kevin Smith go ahead
you
[Music]